hey fun oh thank god soon oh you [ __ ]
Lutz all assemble and have a real
discussion about ok well done that was
just stupid I was I was probably not the
murderer
all right it's it's ernõ would a Luger
oh you start again that was uncalled for
us what that was yeah Wade or Johnny
Wade yeah Bobby dude Bobby I found the
best shiny thing I'm bringing it to the
main lobby I'm trying to find this like
that scared the DA ha ha I knew it if
one but I'm not the evil person I don't
I don't remember who killed me whip it
in the eye and say you're innocent
wait the corner not pay attention okay
let's actually bring our shinies
to the main room how about that Oh shiny
so go find your perfect shine oh that is
a nice shiny got to go shiny wanted that
shiny me oh oh don't work for me there
we go I got it aah what they were gonna
go okay that's a nice shiny but I'm
gonna go get the better shiny seat wait
oh I have the best shiny shiny God who
keeps taking my shinies I have it why I
wanted that shiny good work I'll give it
to you
uh-oh uh-oh another one that's equally
as good please don't stab me tango hold
on my shiny yeah yeah uh be good what I
did not do to it I got shiny bottles of
booze does anyone want them we can we
can see each other by our Chinese that
we carry in the air kiss okay so we got
Chinese here how in the hell do I get
out of here where are you I'm trapped in
the basement I'm an idiot apparently and
I'm coming down
you broke your bottle
there's more whatever oh oh hey see the
shiny was gonna be the death of you nine
uh uh what it was my shot no no no no
thanks running away from me and I'm in a
sense of tangos probably out the killer
which means it's either golf or Zulu
okay I got my shininess don't care about
it's actually okay golf's got the gun
what you gonna shoot me you can't all
hit is bulletproof Oh
nah nah what nope ain't havin no no
shoot my shiny shoot shoot
look out oh god no no how do you pick up
the guy oh why aren't you dead weren't
you dead now he's dead
hi up there hi what you doing what you
doing what you doing you want me to come
up there you want me to come up there
let me come up there
throw what you won do what you want wake
up
Oh God oh hi yourself
evil come on you got jumped off I can't
jump off do you going over there you
over you good ah ha what's trouble he
was close he almost had her all right
who's out here alright who's out here
hey backs up against the wall alright
alright oh no no no no no I will ah okay
this corner papa
you want your face blown off papa you
want to I think Papa might be the murder
big Papa are you
miles Bravo Hey look I got the gun
hey uh hey tango come here that is why
do you stand still wait for you papa
I was Papa you're Bella extraction thank
you yeah thanks Wade that's me hi I'm
crouched so this one has a gun or an
ayat you see what he's doing he's doing
Oh God you still use the gun I'm right
that's a good look Dewey
Clark what kill me no I want you to it
no no no no papa
no let's let it happen here I just stand
underneath you and you can watch me now
understand like why I the choice Bree
you and Bob who else was I gonna chew uh
well I'm blind
Papa please lb I blind I can't see I'm
not guarding you papa just stands up
totally totally blind I can't offer you
oh sorry
how'd it get around us ah okay she's
just hiding waiting for you to come find
him it's - Papa bride oh hey zombie he
didn't see her until after I had already
freaked out by - I thought you were
blind you guys like one oh god those
most pathetic round ever these all the
server's murder only to kill one person
they were blind and hiding in the corner
Wow who Zulu who's Ruby who Zulu wait it
is well you said you just got killed
now last round by you know you said you
chicks got killed this time you're being
very suspicious
you gonna murder me for no reason to get
it all I missed Hey well it's like a yes
you can hear this bomb oh there you are
okay so what's going on
Mark's hiding in the corner with a gun
yeah
Juliet's running around quietly and then
there's you somewhere I am uh I'm doing
nothing that's what I'm doing okay don't
don't worry about me
who are you I'm papa okay so it's
probably me I did night threw the knife
oh you [ __ ] you demand for penis
still I no end in sight